it's just so cool to see the
perspective of how i felt when i was
that age and not knowing what was to
come this has definitely been super
emotional to watch
on set of lonely justin speaks from the
heart about his latest song
it's his fifth one with benny blanco
their most notable collaboration was
love yourself which was nominated in
2015
for two grammy awards the two go all the
way back
to 2010 with justin's my world 2.0
but after 10 years of working with the
superstar benny c is lonely
as justin's most vulnerable song you
know he's got to play superman all the
time
you know who's who's the person taking
care of him
luckily bieber now has someone by his
side every step of the way
his wife haley what does she bring to
his life that you see makes him better
she's the best they're honestly like
they're
they're perfect for each other he seems
like in such a good space and every
experience i've had with her is like
a joy and and she's very caring in
general and
yeah i think they complement each other
this is terrifying
whose idea was this daddy the emotion is
really raw and i think that
fans fans of his
would be eager to hear this side to get
sort of maybe confirmation about what
they think about
how he must have felt growing up cause
i've had
everything but no one's listening
everyone expects justin to be like this
like oh you got
you got everything man like life's great
i think he finally came to the point
where he was like well
you know if i can expose you know even
my life
you know i this is what i told him if
you can expose even your life
for everything you have like you still
have the same problems as everybody else
and
success and all that doesn't matter it's
like everybody still
you know gets upset gets sad feels alone
feels depressed i think him knowing that
people could hear that and be like oh my
god i'm not the only one like
i think it was like it was so important
for him to put out